[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHUCK RHOADES: So my
name is Chuck Rhoades.
I am a senior manager of digital
infrastructure for Pizza Hut.
And today, I'm
going to be talking
to you about microservices
born, raised,
and growing on Google Cloud.
And so, for us, this is
really a customer journey.
So we started working on
building out our service
infrastructure on Google
Cloud last summer--
so about a year ago.
And we've been able to do a lot
in that time and move forward.
So as it's a journey, we'll
kind of talk through it
in those phases.
So to start with, we had a plan.
We wanted to build
a microservice mesh
using containerized architecture
in a public cloud environment.
And so, as we
started that, we knew
there were a few key
things we wanted to do.
So we wanted to use
Kubernetes for orchestration.
And since this is a
Google conference,
I'll just go right
ahead and assume
that we have all
agreed that Kubernetes
is the best orchestration tool.
But we did do our research.
We didn't just start there.
We looked at other options.
We looked at other technologies.
And we really
found Kubernetes is
to be the best of
breed for serving
public workloads, private
workloads, and all the things
that we were going to need
to do in our architecture.
Next, we were going to be
writing microservices in Go.
Again, Google conference, so
I'll assume we all know Go
is the best
programming language.
But I'm not trying to
start a fight there,
so its totally OK if
you disagree with me.
But we really felt like
go has a lot of synergies
with container
architectures that
made it a really great fit.
So the ability to compile
down to single buy-in areas
that you can deploy
into a container.
It makes your
images really small.
deployments really small.
And it lets you be
very efficient in how
you are deploying
those containers
into your architecture.
Finally, we had settled on
deploying to Google Cloud.
There were a lot of
reasons for that.
things that went into it.
But key among those
was just simply
Google Kubernetes Engine,
which a year ago was
called the Container Engine.
But it still had a K for
the name, so it works.
It was really the best
way of deploying services
into a public
cloud environment--
not having to
manage masters, not
having to pay for your instances
that your masters are running
on, and really just the ability
to have all of the latest
features of Kubernetes available
in a very timely manner
for deploying your services.
So we had a really good idea of
what our core architecture was
going to look like.
So before we kind
of move forward,
though, we really needed
to think about, what
actually is a microservice?
I've heard this term used
in a lot of different ways,
and I think the meaning
stays a little bit fuzzy.
So as I was preparing
for this talk,
I really started
to kind of second
guess my own ideas
about a microservice
and didn't really want
to be judged harshly.
So I thought, let me go
use Google to find out
what the world says a
microservice is, and I couldn't
find a really great definition.
I found kind of
paragraphs talking
around what
microservices are, but I
did find a set of
general concepts
that I think most
of us can agree on.
Small independent services.
Generally, we're deploying
those either into containers
or virtual machine architectures
with CI/CD pipelines.
And ultimately,
those services are
interacting with one another
through service discovery.
And so, those are
good principles.
Those are sort of good,
basic ways of describing
a microservice architecture,
but it still doesn't really
define what the actual
microservice is.
And I think there is
room there for us to have
different opinions about it.
But for us, the really key
thing was service boundaries.
Where are we drawing
the service boundaries?
Now, what we really
found to be great
guideposts were
sort of two rules.
They're not hard and fast.
We can have some
flexibility, but they sort of
set the upper and
lower boundaries
on how big we're going to make
an individual microservice.
So we said every service
should be as small as possible
while maintaining meaningful
business function.
So when we're trying
to break services down,
I think we've probably all
at some point in our career--
for the software
developers among us--
we've made that mistake of
making a service too small,
and we eventually
found we've just
created an API that we have
to write SQL in or something
like that.
So there is a lower boundary
that is meaningful business
function.
But on the other
side, we want to make
sure that every one
of those services
fully and completely
encapsulates
the data and the function
that it's responsible for.
It can be easy to have some
of these things sort of creep
in to our service
architectures where
we allow our data
to be interacted
with by some other kind of batch
process or something like that.
And almost always, it
gets us in trouble.
So we define these as
sort of our guideposts.
This is what we wanted to stay
between for our microservice
architecture.
So the last thing we
really had to think about
before we could get started
was, what kind of services
are we going to build?
REST is an obvious choice.
It's absolutely ubiquitous.
When we looked at the people
who are most likely going
to be consuming the
services we're building,
this is what they would
be expecting to consume.
They would be expecting JSON web
services over REST protocols.
So it was a very
good, obvious target.
Also, REST is well supported.
I mean, we all know every
programming language
you probably want
to use, you're going
to be able to interact with a
REST service pretty readily.
The downside with
REST, though, for us
was that there's really no
standard core message contract
when it comes to REST services.
And fortunately,
recently, OpenAPI
has really sort of
become a de facto way
of defining those services
and interacting with them,
but it's still an
after-the-fact specification,
and we're relying on the
effort of the developer
and sort of our reliability to
be rigorous in how we define
our services to have those
OpenAPI specs actually
mean anything.
We've probably
had the experience
of interacting with
an API that said
it was going to do one thing
and then it did something else,
and it causes all sorts of bugs
downstream when you're trying
to consume those services.
So the other option
we looked at was gRPC,
and we found a
lot to love there.
As you can probably
guess at this point,
message contract is
really important to us.
It was something we
were really focused on.
And so having protobufs as
the definition of an RPC
be kind of the core piece of
how gRPCs are put together
was a really attractive thing.
And so, if you haven't
had experience with gRPC,
you define those with
a protobuf document.
It's a very clear,
concise definition.
And then, you use a tool called
protoc to generate your stubs
for servers and clients,
documentation, lots of things
through the plugins.
And so, through that, we also
see great tooling around gRPC.
So it was definitely
something we
wanted to target in
our architecture,
but the problem we had was
it's just not as common yet.
It's still new enough.
It's still not something
that every consumer who's
going to pull in your service is
going to be ready to deal with.
And so we wanted to make
sure that our services were
friendly to our
consumers, but we also
wanted to be able to make
the best technical choices
in our architecture.
And so that sort of
leads to how we came up
with a very simple overview
of how we were going
to approach our service mesh.
We drew a big distinction
between a publicly-exposed API
and internal services and in
the microservice architecture.
So we said, for all
of our services,
for all of our business logic--
really the meaningful
bits of what we're doing--
we're going to keep
those as gRPC services,
and we're going to put those
behind cluster IP services
and Kubernetes.
So if you're familiar with
that, cluster IP services
are only available
within the cluster,
which means it's not exposed.
There's no public
IT accessibility.
But all of those services
can talk to one another.
Service discovery works--
all of those things.
And then, we're going to build
a separate kind of service
in our cluster for
our REST servers
that is based off of an open
API specification that is a REST
API that we can expose
via a load balancer server
out to the rest of the world.
The other nice benefit we
get in that arrangement
is each of those
individual gRPC servers
can fully encapsulate the
data they're responsible for.
So we can follow our
service boundary rules,
meaning they have the
administrative points
and functionality in them.
But whenever we create
those REST servers
and we define that
in open API, we
can only pull up the
methods that we actually
want to expose out to
a broader audience.
So this was our idea.
This is where we wanted to go.
And we felt like we had
a really solid plan.
So the next step on our
journey, we had a project--
location, location, location.
So hopefully everyone in this
room shops with Pizza Hut
all the time and you buy
our products online a lot.
And so, as I talk through this,
it will sort of make sense
and you'll kind of recognize
it in your experience.
But our customers need to be
able to find stores online
whenever they want to
place an order with us.
And at this point in time, when
this project came to my team,
we were at a place where
Pizza Hut was in a transition.
We were moving away from a
previous mapping provider
over to Google Maps for all
of our geocoding and customer
address lookup and
things like that.
It provided an
opportunity for us
to also retire an
older service that we
were using to help with
some of that store location
and delivery lookup
stuff and replace that.
So that was our project.
When we bring projects
into our team,
we really like to look at it
from a few specific questions,
and we start with the customer.
What do our customers
need to be able to do?
And for this service, they need
to be able to do two things--
find all the stores in range
of a particular location
and find a single store
that will deliver pizza
to their location.
So these are the two kind
of methods that we see
evolving out of this project.
And then, we look at the
aspects of the service.
What attributes are
really important?
And this is where
we kind of look
at usage patterns and traffic
patterns on the service.
So for this one, we need to
return answers really fast.
We have a very high read load
because those customers are
searching for their location.
That's being looked up.
We also need high availability.
This is the first step to a
customer interacting with us
online.
We want to make sure that's
really available and really
present and we don't
interrupt that ability
to place orders with us.
And finally, we have a low
read load for the service.
We only need to update
data about once an hour.
Our service is not the system
of record for the things
that it's using.
It's really serving as
an online accessibility
point and more of a cache.
So we took that service
architecture we started with
and we said, OK,
how do we break down
the service we need to build?
The first thing was
our service boundaries.
So we started looking at what
RPCs are going to implement,
and we decided we would have
one that's focused on store
information-- so all of the
things you need to know when
you find your store, as far as
where it is or what's its phone
number--
and a separate one that would be
focused on location type data--
so this would be the thing
that's doing our geoqueries
and handling that information.
And when you look at
it, you may say, well,
it's all really
still about storage,
so why isn't this one service?
And we had that
debate internally.
And actually, in an early
prototype, it was one service.
But again, we look back
at our service boundaries
and how we wanted
to define those.
And we said, we want to make
the services as small as we can
while maintaining
business functions.
So we can break these
in two, so we're
going to go ahead and do that.
So we had to backend
RPC services supporting
all the methods that we need
to interact with our data,
and then we pulled up
those two functions--
finding your delivery
store and finding
stores near a particular
location-- into our REST API.
But no service works
without data behind it,
so we needed to solve
for data storage.
And I've been around for a
little while, long enough
to go from talking about gray
beards to having a lot of gray
in my beard.
So I definitely come from
that architectural approach
where we would start
with just one database,
and we kind of throw
everything at it
and kind of torque
every use case
we had to fit an RDBMS
system and things like that.
So we didn't want
to do that here.
We're in the cloud now.
We should be able to do
things in a different way.
So we wanted to pick our
data storage solution based
on the requirements we had.
So we said we need
high speed reads.
We have queries that are
going to be very key-centric.
Our location service is
taking care of indexing
and a lot of the
geospatial stuff
and really gets us down to
a point where we're just
doing very key-centric
reads, so we
need something that can
handle that really well.
And then, we need
multi-region scale--
again, high availability
for our customers.
We want to make sure
that whatever data
solution we're using has that
same availability kind of thing
to it.
So as we looked at the
options that were out there,
we also looked at some
of the other offerings
in Google Cloud.
We're only using Kubernetes
Engine at this point.
And Datastore actually
solved really a lot
of the main concerns we had.
It will scale to
hundreds of thousands
of read operations per
second, so that definitely
will cover the scale we need.
The key query performance
is amazingly fast,
and so that was going
to be a really good fit.
And it's just
multi-region built-in.
Whenever you provision
out your data store,
you choose a
multi-region region,
and you're up and running and
you have multi-region support.
So we added Datastore to
the backend of our cluster.
We're kind of starting
to pick up steam.
We have a full solution.
We actually can
send queries to it.
We can do things with it.
But we need to
think about, how are
we going to get our data in?
And so this is really,
like I said, a journey.
We didn't know
everything going in.
When we looked at
Kubernetes Engine,
we were really
only looking at it
from sort of that
very specific lane of,
I'm going to have queries
coming in from the web.
I need to service
those and return those.
We weren't thinking about
other kinds of workloads.
So we knew we could put our
source data into a Cloud
Storage bucket, but
how are we going to get
it loaded into our databases?
And that's where, fortunately
as we looked through Kubernetes,
we found there's a workload
specifically for that.
Kubernetes has the
concept of a job,
and so we could simply
create that job.
We could schedule it to run.
And one of the great
side effects of that
was, being that the job
is running in cluster,
we don't have to worry
about extending the methods
that job needs to operate
outside of the cluster
boundary.
So that worked out
for us really well.
But then, we needed to
think about API management.
So we have a service
that ultimately we
are going to be
exposing publicly,
and we are going to
have consumers outside
of Pizza Hut hitting.
So we need the proper security
and management around that.
For this particular
service, we were
going to use API keys as the
appropriate way of securing
the API, but we also wanted
support for JWT tokens.
We knew that we would
be building services
that we would have kind of a
higher need for authorisation
on.
We also wanted usage reports
and performance statistics--
what's happening with the
service as we're using them.
And we want to integrate
with those OpenAPI specs.
We made such a big deal about
having that message contract,
we wanted to make sure whatever
API management platform we're
using integrates with that.
Again, we looked at the service
offerings in Google Cloud.
We compared that
to other options.
And we really settled
on Cloud Endpoints
as being a really
great fit for where
we were in building and
working on our API platform.
So Cloud Endpoints has a
really, really flexible set
of security options.
It's configured declaratively.
Obviously, it supports API keys.
It supports JWT tokens.
And it has pluggable
backend, so you can use
[? Google's ?]
[? off ?] for that.
You can use your own.
There's a rich dashboard
integrated directly
into your Cloud console
for your Cloud Endpoints,
so you can very easily
look at usage by API keys.
You can see the
performance statistics
across your API endpoints
and a lot of the things
we needed to see.
And finally, it is
configured and deployed
with OpenAPI specs.
So just by tweaking
a couple of things
in a couple of places on
our API specifications,
we were able to just immediately
deploy the Cloud Endpoint.
I do want to zoom
in a little bit
on one of the workloads we've
been talking about, though.
So that REST service
that we have deployed,
when we look at the kind of
Kubernetes components of that,
we have a Kubernetes
service that's
the load balancer
targeting port 443.
And then, we have a REST
API, a Kubernetes deployment.
And at the time, we just
had a single service
in the pod, our REST
server that we built.
The great thing
with implementing
Cloud Endpoints was it was
really just a pretty minor
change to that workload.
You add a declaration for the
ESP container to your pod.
And the ESP is the
Extensible Service Proxy.
That's actually
the component that
implements Cloud Endpoints.
And then, we just made
a little port adjustment
so our REST server is on
a separate port that's
only available on the pod.
And then, the service
container can proxy to it.
We're only exposing the service
through a protected channel,
and we didn't really have to
change our architecture that
much.
We just added endpoints
to our REST containers,
and we were in good
shape and ready to go.
So next step, we needed to
think about high availability.
So we've kind of talked about
how we crafted the cluster
and how we put that together,
but we're still really only
talking about a single cluster.
We needed better
availability than that.
So we said, first of all, we can
use a multi-availability zone
cluster.
That's a feature of Google
Kubernetes Engine where
you can extend your cluster into
separate availability zones,
and it will distribute
your pods accordingly
so that you have availability
across all of those zones.
At the time we were doing
this, regional clusters
were not a thing
yet, which are now,
and that's probably
what we would do
and what we actually
will do going forward.
But even then, we're
still in a single region,
and you're still
leaving yourself
a certain amount
of exposure anytime
you're building architecture
in a single cloud region.
So what we really wanted was
to have multi-AZ clusters
in multi-region.
So we have east.
We have west.
We have across
availability zones.
But when we do
that, we need a way
to get traffic into those
zones, into those regions.
Unfortunately, we
don't have the ability
to do cross-regional
clustering quite yet,
so we needed something that
would distribute that traffic.
And if you've been using
Google Cloud for long,
you'll probably predict kind
of where we're going with this.
But we needed to be able
to distribute traffic
into our cluster.
We also wanted to make sure
that we're serving customers
from the closest
cluster to them.
So for geographic
availability, you
can be served in San
Fran out of a data center
on the East Coast, but we would
rather that not be the case
if it doesn't have to be.
And finally, we need to
remove unhealthy clusters
from the services automatically.
So Google Load Balancer,
the Global Load Balancer,
solved this.
And it really was just a direct
fit for the use case we had.
It's designed for
multi-region load balancing.
It distributes load
geographically to the nearest
backend by default. And it
has support for health checks,
so you can make sure that your
services come in and go out--
or your backends for your
services as the health profile
changes.
So we put the Google Cloud
Global Load Balancer--
I always say the Google
Cloud Load Balancer--
but we put the
Global Load Balancer
in front of our customers.
And ultimately, our
architecture starts
to look a little like this.
Now, we did have
to make one change.
Today, the Global Load
Balancer does not really
recognize the Kubernetes
cluster as a thing.
It recognizes it as
instance pools of compute.
So the way around that
is to create a node port
service in Kubernetes
that the Cloud Load
Balancer can address.
Fortunately, that's really
pretty straightforward to do.
You create your
node port service.
We left our load
balancer service in place
because we found it was still
beneficial to be able to route
traffic directly to regions
for testing and seeing
what's going on there.
But it got us to
this point where
we had sort of fully
rationalized and fleshed
out architecture, so
we implemented it,
and we turned it on.
And it worked really well.
It actually served
traffic really well.
This was in place last year
through the Super Bowl,
which is our Super Bowl.
A lot of businesses talk
about what day of the year
is their Super Bowl.
For Pizza Hut, it is
actually the Super Bowl.
So this did a really great job.
It performed really well.
The architecture scaled as we
hoped and expected it would.
But along the way,
what did we learn?
And the answer would be a lot.
We learned a lot of things.
And I think most
of what I've been
talking about up to
this point really
was us learning as we went--
learning that we needed
API management, what
was that going to
look like, learning
about needing load
balancing, what
is that going to look like.
But I really want to highlight
a few specific things
sort of from we were right--
we learned-- to we were wrong.
And so we'll start with we
were right because it's always
great to start on a high note.
gRPCs with well-defined
service boundaries
worked really, really well.
So as of right now, we are
going through a lot of upgrades
and some feature changes to
some of those early services we
built. And what we've
really been happy to find
is that, by having
those service boundaries
and having them
written in RPCs, we
can really trust
those protobufs to be
the thing we need to target.
The experience a lot of
us as software developers
have had of just
implement the interface
and your implementation
will be fine--
mostly-- we do get the
ability to carry that
into our service architecture.
So we can say,
implement the protobuf,
and then do all your
performance and load
testing everything you need.
But you can trust
that your consumers
are going to be OK because
you implemented the protobuf.
So that worked
really, really well.
What we were kind of pleased--
I don't know if surprised is the
right word, maybe delighted--
but Stackdriver
actually turned out
to be a really amazing
toolset for us.
We knew, in a
distributed architecture,
we're going to need
to be able to know
what's going on
with our services
and how's everything performing.
So having Stackdriver
logging and tracing available
was really a huge benefit to us.
From the very beginning, we
were structuring our logs
so that, when they did hit
whatever downstream log system
they would go to, they would
be searchable and accessible.
The integration between
Kubernetes Engines
and Stackdriver, though, just
sort of made all that work.
We just write the log
out like we always
would with whatever
components we want,
and they show up in
Stackdriver fully broken
down so that we can search,
we can create metrics,
and do all of those things.
And then, tracing,
we did see that we
needed to do distributed
trace from the beginning.
So we said, we'll
implement this.
We'll put it in
all our services.
And we'll wrap all of our
callouts in a trace boundary.
And we'll be able to kind of see
how the service is performing.
And so it was kind of
cool to look at the charts
and pull it to the beginning,
and so it was kind of fine.
But then, we noticed on one
of the services in particular
that about a third
of the traffic
was significantly more
latent than the rest
of the traffic in the service--
and so much so that
was really noticeable.
When we looked at the
performance graph,
you sort of had these two peaks.
There was one big glut
of all the traffic
and then like 100-millisecond
delay and a second peak.
And so that was problematic.
Why is a third of our
traffic so much slower
than the other traffic?
And the good news was it
was really easy to find out.
We just simply went in, and we
clicked on a few of the traces.
And fortunately, we had wrapped
the problem area in a boundary.
And so we saw there
was a callout.
There was a place in
that service where,
under certain
conditions, we would
call to geocode a particular
piece of information.
And it was something
that was cacheable.
It wasn't really
customer specific.
But it's one of those
situations where,
because it was
sort of downstream
of so many other things,
it just kind of got
wrapped in a library and
wrapped in a library,
and we didn't really count
the cost of the call anymore.
But through tracing, we
were able to identify it.
We switched that over
so that we did properly
cache that response.
And we got rid of
that second peak
and moved all of our
traffic back together.
So from there, we loved
tracing even more.
Then, we noticed
actually it's better
than we thought because tracing
is great across our services,
but it also integrates
to Cloud Endpoints
and it integrates to Datastore.
So now, I have a very rich
amount of detail all the way
from the point where traffic
enters into my endpoint, what
Cloud Endpoints does with it,
what latency that introduces,
all the way through
my architecture,
and then what's happening
in the database--
which is a really wonderful
amount of visibility
into what's going on
with our services.
And finally, we also learned
that our REST layer that we
talked about, it does work.
It lets us do the
things we wanted
to do as far as pulling
services up out of the RPCs
for exposing those
to public, but it
gets a bit boilerplate-ish.
Most of the time as
we're implementing
that, we're sort
of just recreating
a call, an OpenAPI that we
already created in protobuf,
and passing it through.
And developers love
writing boilerplate,
so we left it in
place for a while.
But then, they told
me I was wrong.
They don't love
writing boilerplate,
so we started looking
at other solutions.
And that kind of takes us into
where are we going from here.
So where are we going?
We have several different areas
that we're looking into now.
So one of those is Istio.
And if you're looking for
me during the conference,
go to any of the Istio talks.
You'll probably find
me there because I'm
attending as many as I can.
We really think
Istio is going to be
an amazing expansion to what we
do in container architectures.
So if you've worked
in Kubernetes,
you know it does do a really
great job of managing services,
but there are still some
things you're doing yourself
or some things that are left
to the developer to implement.
So Istio solves a lot
of those challenges.
So one of the things just
with proxying traffic
throughout your cluster,
if you implement
an architecture like we
have, you'll see gRPC
is an HTTP/2 service.
And so some of you may have
been thinking as it is going,
like, how did you
solve that problem
of proxying gRPC traffic
inside of Kubernetes?
And with a lot of work,
that's how we solved it.
Istio has that built into it.
It is HTTP/2 aware
whenever it's distributing
traffic inside of the
cluster, and so that's
a really huge benefit.
The other thing is, once
you have an architecture
sort of scaled out the way ours
is, you start to have routing
at a lot of different places.
You have some DNS
stuff going on.
You have some routing in
your Global Load Balancer.
Each of your Kubernetes
load balancers
are implementing their
own load balancer,
and so you have routing in that.
And you ultimately kind of have
how your services are routing
to and through the clusters
is a little bit kind of spread
around.
With Istio, you can declare
all of that routing in-cluster
and have it really take
care of managing everything
once it makes it into
the mesh ingress.
And finally, mutual TLS
for service-to-service
authentication.
So we've really
been looking a lot
at how we're doing
defense in-depth
and where we want
to go with that,
and Istio just meshes
in really well with what
we want to achieve there.
Next, so we talked
about that problem
of having those
sort of REST APIs.
And the main use case
we had for that was we
need to be able
to kind of cherry
pick specific
methods out of RPCs,
mix those together,
and sometimes transform
the requests and
responses away from what
we would do in the
RPC to something
that's more specific to
a particular consumer.
And so, really,
what I've described
there is a lot of what
Apigee actually does.
So as we have
matured our services
and we've looked at moving
into a little bit more
of a full-featured
API management suite,
we're moving in that direction.
And so, again, as I was
talking about gRPC and REST,
some of you guys probably
thought about, why didn't you
look at the gRPC
gateway because that's
pretty much what it does?
It takes your protobuf.
It compiles out a
REST proxy for that.
And so that's
actually the direction
we're going to be going now.
So we'll be wrapping everything
in gRPC gateway proxies.
That will expose those as
APIs up into our Apigee layer.
And then, from there,
we will be able to pick
which endpoints we want.
We'll combine those into
products within Apigee
and do the transformations
and all of the things
we need to do there.
And then, where
else are we going?
More and more and more
and more services.
So I really kind of
talked through a use case
with two services.
We've grown well past that.
We've had several other
projects where we've introduced
many additional services.
And we look a little bit
more like that initial map
where not everything is just a
service exposed through a REST.
We have things that are purely
internal to the cluster.
We have things that are wrapping
calls out to the broader world.
We actually brought in
other cloud products.
So I didn't have a chance
in this particular use case
to talk about Cloud
Pub/Sub, but that's
become a really significant part
of our architecture as well,
and we found
anywhere that we need
to do an asynchronous
payload it's fit extremely
well into what we're
putting together
and how we're
approaching things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]